des syndicalistes des présidents
d'organismes représentant soit des
sociétés certain nombre d'investigations
qui ont été menées avec le rapporteur ou
représentants de métiers et notamment de
métiers du sport dans le football métier
collectif se poser la problématique je
dirais de la participation à
l'individuelle d'un certain nombre de
nos compatriotes face à un sujet qui est
vaste et notamment dans les métiers
individuel il n'était pas facile
d'individualiser je dirais que tel
métier ou de catégories où les artistes
les acteurs de cinéma et donc c'est tout
à fait je dirais naturellement que l'on
a essayé de voir dans quelle mesure on
pouvait auditionné des personnalités
répondant à la problématique qui nous
intéresse mais qui ne parlait pas en
fonction d'une fonction je dirais de
président ou de syndicats d'un d'une
fonction d'une corporation et le titre
individuel
donc je vous remercie de votre présence
d'autant plus que c'est la première
audition qui a lieu après une longue
période électorale dans notre pays et
que donc je dirais le sénat retrouve sa
sérénité naturelle pour reprendre les
travaux avec le sérieux en espère que on
développe dans cette maison et ne
restait que très peu de temps aux
rapporteurs monsieur bloqué pour
soumettre à ses collègues un rapport
puisqu'il sera remis le 20 juin
vous voyez que nous avons un
espace-temps relative en aiguille enfin
en préambule je souhaitais dire que l'un
de nos collègues contenu
je dirais de d'une procédure avec l'un
d'entre vous a souhaité faire en sorte
que les travaux puissent se dérouler
tout à fait sereinement donc ne
participe pas et je vais m'excuser
auprès des autres membres de la
commission ne participe pas à cette audi
donc maintenant je vais commencer
l'audition alors messieurs je vous
rappelle que conformément aux termes de
l'article 6 de l'ordonance 17 novembre
58 relatives au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires votre audition
doit se tenir sous serment et que tout
faux témoignage est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 400 34-13 et 400
34-15 du code pénal en conséquence je
vais vous demander de prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
pour ce faire vous devrez la main droite
et vous direz je le jure donc si vous
voulez bien me suis forgé peut-être trop
merci monsieur noir merci beaucoup
alors je ne sais pas si vous avez eu
quelques propositions auxquelles un
propos introductif éliminèrent a proposé
aux membres de la commission en fonction
je dirais des interrogations qui ont été
suscités par les administrateurs de la
commission ou si vous souhaitez
compassion directement à mécanisme des
questions et des réponses mais si vous
avez des préliminaires vous avez la
parole donc pas particulièrement mon
poste commence
bon alors je vais passer la parole à
notre rapporteur chez boké bien très
bien merci monsieur le président donc
merci messieurs d'avoir accepté le cette
invitation à être auditionné donc face à
la commission d' enquête qui nous
intéresse depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois
donc ce n'est pas en tant qu'initiateur
des systèmes que vous êtes ici ce matin
mais monsieur le président l'a rappelé
nous avons auditionné
pas moins d'une centaine de personnes
depuis le début entrepreneurs les grands
groupes les banques avocat fiscaliste
syndicalistes journalistes
d'investigation les services de bercy
dont qui nous permet d'avoir un regard
global sur le sujet nous avons effectué
certains déplacements à jersey notamment
à bruxelles et nous serons en suisse
cette fin de semaine et à la city à
londres lundi prochain et je pense que
nous aurons au terme de ses travaux une
vision assez générale de la situation au
regard de cette problématique de
l'évasion fiscale de l'exil fiscal et
donc nous avons effectivement
souhaitez-vous recevoir vous en dis
auditionné parce qu'on voulait aussi
s'intéresser au monde le nombre des
sportifs et au monde des artistes qui
peut être concerné par le sujet donc je
pense qu'il était justifié que nous vous
entendons et encore une fois je vous
remercie de vous être prêté finalement à
7 à cet exercice de vérité qui demande
un certain courage dont vous appartenez
sans doute à une catégorie de français
qui perçoit des revenus élevés
par ailleurs vous avez une grande
notoriété la présence médiatique
nombreuses en témoigne vous êtes très
populaire vous avez une grande
visibilité nationale et internationale
et justement dans le cas de la
mondialisation vous avez été amené
vous avez été amené à évoluer dans des
ensembles très internationalisées donc
l'un des aspects de l'évasion fiscale
s'appuie sur la concurrence effrénée que
se mènent les pays sur ce domaine
voilà donc ma première question a trait
à votre perception du système fiscal
français mais aussi en parallèle à ce
que vous avez pu ressentir au cours de
vos rencontres des systèmes fiscaux des
pays où vous avez été amené à
fonctionner ou séjourné au cours de
votre carrière donc j'aimerais avoir un
peu votre perception donc à titre
comparatif entre le système fiscal qui
est le nôtre et les systèmes fiscaux des
pays que vous avez pu fréquenter est ce
que vous pourriez de donner un premier
avis là dessus s'il vous plaît une gros
micro micro
bonjour à tous moi je peux effectivement
vous parler de la problématique enfin en
tout cas de les questions que les
joueurs de tennis se pose lorsque ils
passent effectivement professionnels
comme certains d'entre vous le savent je
vois quelqu'un quelques journalistes
tennistique qui sont là une carrière de
joueur de tennis est finalement assez
courte
on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui dans le
top 100 les joueurs arrivent dans le top
100 à l'âge de 21 22 ans vont arrêter
leur carrière aux alentours de la
trentaine
32-33 pour ceux qui tiennent plus
longtemps donc ça fait des car
effectivement extrêmement courte au
cours desquelles effectivement ils vont
avoir des revenus essentiellement
aujourd'hui sur sur les tournois atp
comme vous le savez depuis maintenant
dix ou quinze ans les prize money dans
les les tournois tout autour de la
planète ont considérablement évolué et
tant mieux pour la profession puisque je
tiens à le rappeler parce que dans le
cadre de deux roland garros aujourd'hui
on a fait évoluer en quelques sortes les
prize money parce qu'il faut savoir
qu'un joueur qui évolue au delà de la
120e place mondiale aujourd'hui ne
rentre pas dans ses frais
donc un joueur qui aujourd'hui 140e 150e
joueur mondial et qui voyage tout au
long de l'année perdre l'argent
lorsqu'il joue le circuit donc pour ce
qui est des des 120 meilleurs lorsqu'ils
y parviennent sur une carrière
finalement très très courte
ils essayent de et là je parle de les
journées sont en général des français
mais d autres d'optimiser finalement
c'est ce temps de jeu puisqu'il voyage
en général ils sont huit mois par an 9
pour certains autour du haut tout autour
du monde
il essaye de trouver fiscalement
effectivement les
les endroits où ils peuvent résider qui
sont pour eux les plus avantageux alors
certains vivent aux états unis en
floride ont fait un état qui est
beaucoup plus tôt avantageux pour
certains sportifs même pour les
américains du reste pour ce qui est des
joueurs italiens parfois allemand on
sait que monaco était une destination
forcément très très intéressante pour ce
qui est des joueurs français certains
son talent en angleterre dont total en
belgique
certains sont allés en suisse tout
simplement pour effectivement optimisé
sur ces huit dix années je dirais l'eure
l'eure enfin tout le prize money qu'ils
allaient pouvoir gagner sur les cours ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que par rapport
aux prélèvements fiscaux tous les pays
vous devez le savoir sont pas du tout à
la même enseigne
d'ailleurs en france lorsqu à l'époque
où lorsque je jouais yannick jouait
aussi on avait un prélèvement
automatique une valeur de 32 ou 33 % qui
était libératoire que payé d'ailleurs
tous les autres joueurs étrangers aussi
ce système a finalement après évolué
puisque aujourd'hui les joueurs français
et étrangers sont imposés sur territoire
français à hauteur de 15% à la suite de
quoi en fin d'année il doit faire une
déclaration complémentaire où ils vont
inclure sur les trois de bercy de roland
garros de metz denise de marseille on a
la chance d'avoir plusieurs tournées en
france ont fait un écart sur total et
moins leurs 15 % ils vont payer le
complément est le complément pour
effectivement vous en doutez pour les
meilleurs sanctions en tout cas dans les
50 meilleurs il dépasse le plafond
maximal et certains sont en pause
imposée à bon aujourd'hui c'est
quasiment 50%
bien sûr pour les joueurs français et
pour les joueurs étrangers
aujourd'hui tous les joueurs de tennis
professionnels au delà d'un certain
plafond sont imposés dans ses montants
la chose qui n a jamais être amené à
évoluer avec les
la prochaine tranche fiscale et c'est
pas pareil dans tous les pays il ya
d'autres il ya d'autres pays aujourd'hui
où là où la fiscalité en europe et bien
sûr notre pays beaucoup plus légère
ailleurs tout est une question sur le
fond à revenir plus tard parce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui certains joueurs qui
lorsqu'ils ont choix entre revenir jouer
en france
je parle des bons joueurs et être
imposée à 50% ont peut-être à l'avenir
plus et jouer dans un autre pays voisin
où il y aura une fiscalité qui sera plus
légère ils feront le choix justement de
de jouer dans ces autres tournois
services de pénaliser je dirais les
tournois français voilà après qu'est ce
que je peux rajouter que effectivement
les joueurs dont j'ai fait partie
lorsque je jouais sur le circuit
lorsqu'on a décidé de 2,2 de résider à
l'étranger c'était justement pour pas
avoir géré une double imposition pour ma
part je suis j'étais résident en suisse
c'est un pays qui fait pas la double
imposition et lorsqu'il y avait lorsque
j'ai payé un montant aux états unis de
l'ordre de 30 ou 35% prélèvements
obligatoires moi qui ne suis pas au
forfait en suisse qui paye mes impôts
comme un comme un suisse je n'ai pas de
double imposition derrière les joueurs
français qui résident en france
lorsqu'il 30% aux etats-unis bas sont
imposés sur ce montant là qu'ils aient
gagné à l'extérieur du territoire pour
la plupart des joueurs jouent quand même
beaucoup beaucoup à l'étranger sont
imposés une deuxième fois sur sur ces
montants là c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles entre autres beaucoup d'entre
eux aujourd'hui choisissent de
s'expatrier pendant le temps de leur
carrière pour justement optimisé ne pas
avoir cette double imposition qui
finalement pour rené les patrons n'est
pas très avantageuses voilà je sais pas
si j'étais assez clair où vous avez
évoqué les états unis et qui vous le
savez ont pris des mesures par rapport à
la fiscalité de leurs ressortissants et
notamment établi des règles fiscales qui
imposent leurs nationaux quelles que
soient leurs yeux
silence alors est-ce que ça constitue
une exception américaine et considérez
vous que nous pourrions en france
aménager notre loi fiscale pour réduire
les incitations à l'exil fiscal
ça pourrait être une des propositions
que nous ferons dans le rapport quel est
votre sentiment sur cet aspect l'un et
l'autre s'il vous plaît écoutez je crois
qu'aujourd'hui façon toute personne ne
doit enfin personne se soumet à l'impôt
quel que soit l'endroit où où le sportif
via son activité j'ai lorsque c'est aux
états unis que les joueurs de français
et étrangers doivent payer les ses 32 ou
33 % suivant les états il s'en acquitte
lorsque c'est en france et que rafael
nadal gagne roland garros
parfois même bercy et lorsqu'il est
imposé à plus de 50% ou à l'avenir ce
qui sera le cas il le fera et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les joueurs les sportifs
n'ont pas d'autres options aujourd'hui
que de s'acquitter de ce qu'il aurait dû
m'en réclame et on revenir une nouvelle
fois aux joueurs de tennis sachant
qu'ils passent huit mois par an souvent
à l'étranger certains choisi justement
de s'exiler fiscalement pour optimiser
vidzone ses huit années là ce cet écart
qui peut être de l'ordre de 15 à 20 %
parfois lorsqu'ils vont rater leur
carrière pour certains dont je fais
partie on n'a pas notre baccalauréat
il faut repartir dans une autre vie
repartir de zéro et pour certains
d'avoir eu justement ce ce petit ce
petit matelas de côté valeurs permet de
repartir manière plus sereine après là
encore dire chaque pays doit
propose des nouvelles des nouvelles lois
et j'irai que tous les sportifs comme
tous les citoyens de tous les deux tout
les les pays du monde géré se soumettent
à ces ac a ses lois votre réaction
avec cette proposition qui apparemment
on va devenir une réalité d'une création
d'une tranche à 75% idée lancée pendant
la campagne des présidentielles qui
devrait aboutir effectivement une
disposition légale
quel est votre sentiment sur cette
proposition s'il vous plaît bonjour
messieurs dames
en fait il ya deux aspects l'aspect qui
a parlé donc de la position des joueurs
de tennis professionnels
lorsqu'il part d'aider les joueurs de
tennis professionnels ils parlent d'une
va parler d'une cinquantaine de joueurs
qui sont concernés centaine de joueurs
concernés là pour ce qui est de 2,2
cette proposition à la on parle bien
entendu d on continue à parler d'homme
de joueur de tennis
il ya deux aspects il est certain que
certains joueurs vont peut-être se
retrouver refroidir froid dit par le
fait d'être obligé de payer une telle
somme autant d'impôts ma faim il faudra
savoir que c'est quand même et ça reste
quand même une minorité que lorsqu'on
joue un tournoi comme roland-garros soit
bercy même si on parle beaucoup de prize
money ça reste quand même une fenêtre
importante sur le plan international il
ya la tradition du tournoi il ya
l'histoire du tournoi qui fait que même
au delà du breizh monnet on peut
retrouver on peut se retrouver à gagner
et tirer des bénéfices d'une belle
performance à roland garros août sur un
grand tournoi bien au delà du prize
money donc le prize money n'est pas tout
c'est pour ça que je pense que pour
aller plus loin il il est
il serait juste il me semble juste deux
ans sentiment n'est pas partagée par la
plupart de mes confrères
il me semble juste que justement des
joueurs de cet acabit qui lorsqu'il
gagne roland garros dont je connais très
peu de gens qui disent rafael nadal a
gagné 7 roland garros donc à gagner tant
de millions d'euros jeu ça se calcule
pas comme ça et je pense que si
aujourd'hui rafale alors lui proposer de
gagner roland garros gratuitement il
viendrait quand même donc je pense c'est
un débat qui est qui et qui mérite
d'être soulevée mais d'un autre côté il
me semble est en tout cas c'est mon
sentiment que ça me paraît juste quand
quelqu'un qui gagnent autant d'argent
puisse avoir le fait de partager
deuxième si la question avant de passer
la parole à mes collègues dont je sais
que certains souhaitent la prendre on
essaie aussi dans les travaux la
commission de comprendre les mécanismes
à l'oeuvre dans ces dispositions et ces
phénomènes et on voudrait comprendre
aussi les conditions concrètes qui
peuvent amener un sportif de haut niveau
disposant de revenus élevés donc
d'optimiser sa fiscalité
j'imagine que l'entourage doit doit
jouer au niveau des joueurs
professionnels
mais on devrait également comprendre le
rôle des uns et des autres est ce que
c'est l'agent qui intervient un pour un
joueur est ce que c'est une banque
est ce que c'est un avocat fiscaliste
enfin quels sont les rouages de la
mécanique de cette optimisation fiscale
le premier responsable premier motivé
c'est le joueur c'est le joueur qui qui
qui joue enfin qui a une carrière et guy
le soulignait justement c'est une
carrière qui dure dix ans au maximum
quand ça marche bien c'est vrai que
pendant ces dix ans mais le joueur a à
coeur d'optimiser ses gains et de faire
des économies en sachant très bien que
dans 90
18 % 95 % des cas la reconversion reste
un problème très important donc le
calcul est forcément différent parce que
ce sont des carrières qui sont très très
courte
ensuite bien entendu comme disait guy ce
sont les joueurs ont commencé très tôt
leur carrière savoir que là pour la
plupart ont arrêté leurs études milieu
de du secondaire et donc se retrouve
obligé de faire appel à des imprésarios
des avocats des agents qui les guide
ensuite parfois bien parfois moins bien
dans sachant qu'à ce moment là c'est
vrai que c'est l'entourage est
responsable à part pour des gens
branchés qui connaissent bien comme dit
si tu étais très bon pilote et très bon
championnat
oui mais je forge est votre sentiment
là-dessus s'il vous plaît à nommer
certains cas nick l'a bien illustré
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui dès qu'un
jeune joueur commence à pointer le bout
de son nez
il est forcément repérer et par des
marques et par des des agents il ya deux
trois grosses agences de deux joueurs de
tennis aujourd'hui qui sont d'ailleurs
aussi un petit peu dans le foot et qui
forcément
proposent leurs services à ces joueurs
là pour s'occuper de leurs de leur
carrière alors ça va du choix d'un
entraîneur à la négociation des contrats
la négociation de certaines garanties
sur les tournois
jusqu'à leur investissement comment
faire préférer son patrimoine
ça va jusqu'à aussi filmant des conseils
en termes de délocalisation pour pour
avoir une fiscalité plus avantageuse
ça va jusqu'à de l'intendance jusqu'à
des réservations de billets d'avion
jusqu'à donc cdc des organismes qui sont
très connus sur la place publique qui
intervient d'ailleurs dans le monde du
sport et du spectacle aussi qu'ils sont
dans tous les sports la formule 1 dans
le football dans le golfe et aujourd'hui
je dirais que quasiment tous les joueurs
professionnels tous sports confondus
sont aujourd'hui représentés par
quelques-unes de ces grandes maisons
vous imaginez que lorsqu'un joueur
quelque soit le sport à 22 ans 21 ans et
pour la première fois commence à avoir
des rentrées d'argent qui lui permettent
de vivre convenablement et là encore
excepté je veux dire les cinq six
meilleurs joueurs du monde de tennis
gèrent très vite ça dégringole après
pour arriver au 126ème j'ai acquis
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à mettre un
centime de côté à la fin de l'année si
on veut faire un comparatif est que le
football finalement un petit peu les
classes entre les six meilleurs joueurs
du monde sont vraiment dans dans une
catégorie bien à part après il ya les
autres qui sont entre l on va dire
peut-être 6,8 et et 25 qui en vivent
bien qui peut finir leur carrière on est
même en ayant mis un petit pas mal
d'argent de côté
puis après il y en a d'autres qui sont
entre 50 et 100 et qui ce qu'ils ont pu
en fin de carrière ce s'acheter une
jolie maison ou un très bel appartement
à paris et qui bon bain comme les
yannick vont repartir après dans la dans
la vie active donc c'est pour ça que ces
gars on essaye sans savoir jusqu'où ils
vont aller à 21 ou 22 ans très tôt de
d'optimiser c'est à dire en allant
dans un pays voisin où justement ils
vont pouvoir
chaque année économiser un petit peu
plus et ce petit plus ce sera peut-être
là la différence à l'arrivée mais ils
sont effectivement encadré gère la
plupart des joueurs n'ont aucune notion
en c'est vrai qu'en vieillissant un
petit peu on est les joueurs aussi
jouant je vous le dit tout à l'heure
six à sept mois par an à l'étranger
yannick à leur parler des contrats
effectivement il a raison c'est vrai que
pour un joueur comme rafael nadal ou
rodger federer
le prize money qui est qui va enfin
gagner sur les courts et quelque part
inférieure à ce qu'il va voir en
contrats publicitaires
mais là on parle de vraiment de quatre
cinq joueurs qui sont hors normes
tous les autres je veux dire la plupart
des des 100 meilleurs vont gagner
beaucoup plus d'argent je dirais de sur
le sur le circuit avec leurs
performances sur le terrain
d'ailleurs c'est laisser les montants
qui sont complètement officielle voix
sur internet vous c'est le montant que
vous pouvez trouver
ces joueurs là justement essaye de parce
qu'il joue beaucoup à l'étranger de
pannes économiser le plus possible est
ce que est ce que vous avez jusqu'à dire
qu'il ya du démarchage dans les
approches de ces de ses joueurs qui
montent démarchage de l'apport de la
part d'avocats fiscalistes de banques y
compris de banques étrangères parfois et
les structures qui gèrent les contrats
publicitaires lorsqu'ils sont établis
est ce que on peut imaginer que soient
implantées dans des territoires offshore
c'est-à-dire à fiscalité privilégiée
ici et là avez vous été avez vous
connaissance de ce genre de situation
coûtait pas ma connaissance à moi léger
était représentée par une sautée qui se
fait et qui s'appelle img qui nous un
groupe mondialement connu qui ont des
bureaux à paris à londres à new york
sur tous les continents je crois pas
connaître de problèmes en des agents qui
sont free lance qui sont indignes
domicile et ailleurs 20 qui ont leurs
structures dans des sûr d'aider des pays
offshore mais là les grandes maisons
dont je parle qui sont quand même qui
représente peut-être 80 % des joueurs
aujourd'hui et des joueuses sont d'aider
des sociétés qui sont implantés partout
et pour répondre à votre question oui
parfois il ya certaines banques qui
proposent à selon deux de service mais
c'est souvent géré les agents qui
propose justement certaines alternatives
aux joueurs les parents aussi vous savez
très bien d'ailleurs peut-être pas
encore plus chez les chez les jeunes
filles que chez les jeunes garçons les
jeunes filles arrivent parfois sur le
circuit est très très forte à 16 ou 17
ans qui ont ne pas finir leur scolarité
souvent les parents étant omniprésent
c'est les parents qui s'occupent tirait
de tout de tout est à cet aspect fiscal
et qui quelque part se renseigne auprès
de l'agent de banques de pour optimiser
justement ce ses revenus
merci monsieur le rapporteur et alors
nathalie goulet
oui je voudrais d'abord vous remercier
d'être là vous dire qu'une grande partie
des auditions nous avons menées jusqu'à
maintenant nous ont amenés à voir la
différence entre la fraude et
l'optimisation et vous avez tout à fait
clairement expliqué l'optimisation qui
est une procédure absolument légale
d'utilisation absolument normales et
régulières de la législation qui est
appliquée le rapporteur a posé la
question je les propose et donc les
choses se faire une simple une simple
remarque ces cas comme une très grosse
différence avec des individus des
sportifs de haut niveau des danseurs ou
des artistes
et puis des entreprises publiques qui
elles organisent clairement
officiellement des sièges à l'étranger
c'est quand même tout à fait différent
donc mais merci pour ces explications et
je voulais simplement vous dire qu'on
avait aussi en tant que parlementaires
parfois un certain nombre de difficultés
à faire comprendre nos rémunérations nos
modes de retraite et c'est là qu'il ya
un gros problème en france avec les gens
qui gagnent de l'argent et que dans
cette commission nous n'avons absolument
rien et aucune hostilité à l'égard
allait garder des gens qui gagnent
beaucoup d'argent
l'objectif de cette commission était
plutôt d'essayer de comprendre les
mécanismes d'évasion et de faire la
différence avec l'optimisation donc vous
avez clairement expliqué l'optimisation
qui est un sujet qu'on comprend
extrêmement bien donc le rapporteur mme
ayant soufflé ma question je n'ai fait
qu'une petite remarque merci très bien
la question était pour partie abordé par
contre à porter quatre jours complets
remercie à mon tour
guy forget il ya une loi de se prêter à
cet exercice pas toujours facile vous
prévenir donc un peu sur ce sujet qui a
été abordé concernant le degré
d'indépendance qui existe avec ses
structures ou agents
que ce soit pour les artistes à dire ont
pour pour les sportifs
et justement ces structures ne pas aussi
on n'a t'elle pas
à la base au départ beaucoup d'argent au
détriment bien entendu de l'artiste ou
du sportif les structures des conseils
et il convient sans doute de peut-être
de réglementer mieux la profession des
agents nés en temps parce que c'est un
sujet récurrent que qui est souvent
abordée dans cet hémicycle mais toujours
pas réglé écoutez pour enfin je peux
parler que juste d'aider des joueurs de
tennis que j'ai encadré la pas en
quelques années lorsque je jouais
c'était mon cas effectivement c'est ces
agences qui proposent leurs services
forcément se rémunère sur un pourcentage
bien sûr des des contrats qui nous
paraît normal qui paraît normal
maintenant faut savoir c'est pourcentage
c'est sont négociables
c'est pas des choses qui sont fixes
d'ailleurs d'où surgit direct sur les 15
20 dernières années ils ont été revues à
la baisse
lorsque j'ai commencé ma carrière mon
agent percevait plus 25 % de la totalité
de mes contrats et des garanties
et puis c'est descendu petit à petit
parce qu'il ya eu de plus en plus
d'agents et je crois qu'ils ont essayé
de diminuer leurs marges
je crois savoir qu'aujourd'hui certaines
grandes stars à peine moins de 10%
j'irai sur leurs contrats et leurs
garanties à leurs agents donc c'est des
choses comme qui sont assez
enfin assez transparente c'est pas des
choses qui sont arrêtés enfin les
joueurs ont pleinement conscience je
dirais de que ce service forcément parce
qu'il ya vraiment des joueurs qui sont
encadrés de a à z c'est à dire que ce
soit pour reprendre leur fiscalité tout
à l'heure leur résidence principale
selon lagence aucune rita land use comme
un espèce de concierge qui va s'occuper
de l'envoi de ses raquettes de son
matériel de de tous les problèmes
d'intendance qui sont liées à sa
carrière vu qu'il est tout le temps à
l'étranger fragile chaque agent essaye
d'être le plus convaincant possible
d'attirer le plus de joueurs dont qui
propose un tas un tas de services qui
mérite effectivement rémunération
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui je sais qu'il ya
des des agences qui souffrent beaucoup
parce qu'à force de réduire leurs coûts
et on peut tous ces services quand vous
prenez 8% à 10% sur un contrat qui est
pas très important que vous devez suivre
le joueur à l'étranger dans les hôtels
payer une secrétaire et en a qui en ont
beaucoup de mal certains certains sports
sont mieux organisés que d'autres le
tennis est un des premiers sports être
professionnel depuis 68 donc c'était
vraiment des premiers sports les
premiers tournois ont été organisés par
quelqu'un qui est toujours un agent qui
a monté cette agence s'appelle proserv
il était le premier agent qui était
avocat qui était aussi bon joueur de
tennis
donc quand on regarde un peu les
structures de tous les joueurs de tennis
est très bien organisé très
professionnel et à c est plutôt
transparent comparé à d'autres sports où
c'est un petit peu où vous trouvez cette
voix des gens qui sont pas de la
profession et qui se retrouvent agents
et qui eux là peuvent parfois travailler
différemment en tennis assez bien
structuré il ya deux très grosses 3
maintenant atteinte et jeu
j'ai passé existe toujours moi je vous
parle j'ai arrêté de pierre mondy jean
thomas 20 des jeux mg prosser qui
étaient les trois grosses boîtes et qui
est qu'ils avaient tous les joueurs
maintenant et ça a toujours été très
très bien bien organisé on voit par
rapport à d'autres sports j'avais des
copains qui étaient dans notre sport et
cette visite est pas aussi bien encadrés
connu à tous les niveaux à tous les
niveaux oui tout d'abord merci à mon
tour il dit forget
nova d'avoir accepté notre notre
sollicitation
cette audition arrive presque en fin de
parcours
nous allons voir truc d'audition
maintenant il nous permet d'avoir une
vision un peu globale des jo des choses
déjà sur le constat ensuite il restera
travailler sur les solutions à travers
l'audition de deux grand tennisman
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est aussi
l'interrogation par rapport à un sportif
de très haut niveau en général aux
hommes et femmes de spectacles également
qui du fait de leur statut et du fait de
leurs gains sont années parfois être
imposables en dehors de nos frontières
donc c'est pas spécifiquement le
l'utilisent qui est aujourd'hui visé à
travers cette solution apparaît assez
important de souligner par ailleurs
dans son des auditions nous montre
aujourd'hui que la grande partie de
l'évasion et la fraude fiscale ne
viennent pas des particuliers sportifs
ou mais femme de spectacle mais me
semble-t-il plutôt du monde de
l'économie ou de particuliers très
fortunés qui ont eu à un moment donné
peut-être ou pas je n'en sais rien la
chance d'avoir de gros héritages et donc
de cacher le patrimoine dont il dispose
et donc c'est pas uniquement au niveau
du revenu en termes d'échelle pour
autant constate bien que nous vivons une
telle période que l'exemplarité est
considérablement importante et je crois
que c'est plus à ce titre là
qu'aujourd'hui nous auditionnons je
comprends bien après avoir entendu
monsieur forgé en partie v que les
joueurs de tennis qui sont classés au
delà du 120e mondial n'ont pas de
problématique fiscale puisque leur
rémunération ne conduit pas forcément à
voir niveau de vie extraordinaire donc
ceux qui sont visés et notamment aux
titres d'exemplarité ce sont plutôt les
joueurs de très haut niveau et de
premier rang la même chose pour le
football la même chose dans d'autres
domaines plus plus artistique c'est
l'exemplarité dans le domaine du sport
en particulier à partir du moment où ses
joueurs puisque nous parlons du tennis
ou joueuses ont bénéficié quand même de
l'environnement sportif de
l'environnement en termes d'éducation
d'un pays comme la france il ne semble
pas illogique mais c'est pas du tout ce
qui a été dit hein mais il ne semble pas
illogique qu'ils puissent rendre à un
moment donné ce qui leur a été
collectivement à porter et notamment par
l'aide fiscale de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
alors maintenant ça c'est l'aspect
collectif ya l'aspect individuel qui
font entendre une carrière courte et du
coup c'est du ressort de la collectivité
également de prendre en compte ce
phénomène que la carrière est courte et
c'est aberrant de constater parfois que
de grands champions olympiques qui ont
amené
l'honneur à notre pays par
l'intermédiaire de médailles d'or par
exemple qui dix ou quinze ans après se
retrouve dans une extrême pauvreté
il a globalement ça signifie quoi ça
signifie qu'à partir du moment où un
homme une femme à porter haut l'honneur
de notre pays
il doit aussi collectivement considéré
nous devons collectivement considérer
que c'est la responsabilité de la nation
de leur permettre de vivre décemment
jusqu'à la fin une d'argent alors
ensuite ça suppose bien entendu d'aller
beaucoup plus profondément dans cette
réflexion là mais au minimum me
semble-t-il à partir du moment où
quelqu'un de très haut niveau a apporté
beaucoup à notre pays en termes de
donneurs et de représentation
étant membre d'une équipe de france mais
quelles qu'elles soient et quelle que
soit la discipline par ailleurs il
semble logique que au minimum ensuite il
est d'autre part qu'ils soient au
minimum du salaire médian moyens
salaires médians ça suppose bien entendu
une réflexion
importante et sur les 75 % j'ai beaucoup
apprécié la réflexion que la réponse
mais nous la connaissions déjà de de
yannick noah à savoir que à partir du
moment où on ne gagne plus d'un million
par an j'ai entendu nathalie goulet
c'est pas le niveau des parlementaires
ont gardé quelque chose qui m'a échappé
un mais payer 75% au dessus d'un million
et seulement à partir d'un million
s'adapte ça n'est pas aberrant c'est en
termes d'exemplarité que cela se pose
notamment dans la situation dans
laquelle le pays se trouve aujourd'hui
et donc j'ai apprécié la réponse de nick
noah notamment en évoquant la nécessité
d'une indispensable solidarité qui
finalement est une solidarité citoyenne
qui doit être comprise par tous et donc
je pense qu'en termes d'exemplarité il
est indispensable à la fois de tenir
compte des carrières courtes
il faut que le législateur en tiennent
compte et en même temps que ceux qui ont
la chance de gagner beaucoup se rendent
compte que l'exemplarité c'est aussi de
payer au pot commun pour payer les
services publics pour payer la formation
des futurs joueurs de tennis et donc
d'aller dans ce sens d'une
responsabilité et de l'exemplarité qui
dans la période mais pas seulement
un pareil je crois tout ce responsable
et donc chers collègues c'était un
commentaire pas de questions
particulières de la question
particulière c'est de savoir si
éventuellement il partage ainsi s'ils
partagent ce point de vue qu'à partir du
moment où un joueur de tennis puisque
nous évoquons cette discipline
aujourd'hui à bénéficier de la formation
de l'éducation
dans notre pays est ce qu'il n'est pas
logique mais j'ai cru entendre déjà la
réponse est logique et une participation
à la solidarit nationale solidarité
nationale à un moment donné ensuite la
deuxième question est ce qu'il pense
qu'il est logique qu à partir du moment
où un homme une femme à porter haut les
couleurs de notre pays il est logique
que la collectivité nationale assure
l'avenir de cet homme ou de cette femme
ensuite lorsqu'il a terminé sa carrière
bien je parlais du jeu devrait connaître
les micros je parlais du tennis c'est
vrai que l'organisation du tennis nous
avons eu un système de retraite en fait
qui permet de l'accompagner les joueurs
qui en ont besoin
donc on n'arrive pas dans les cas de
figure où certains d'entre nous se
retrouve complètement laissée à
l'abandon ou démunies mais c'est à ccc
une organisation qui est propre au
tennis tu me reprend si les bêtises
violence et c'est que c'est correct
c'est une petite retraite mais
effectivement la tp qui est
l'association des joueurs de tennis
professionnels sur chaque événement
prélève un pourcentage jugement du prize
money pour l'euro mais dans un espèce de
pot commun et des joueurs qui ont passé
une dizaine d'années dans le top 100
d'ailleurs yannick va commencer à le
toucher bientôt je crois parce qu'il a
l'âge
des mensualités voilà où qu'elle soit
dans le besoin bien la parole à monsieur
guerriau oui jacques gaillot centre de
l'atlantique jeu plaisir unique de te
recevoir l'année dernière à saint
sébastien où tu as fait un excellent
concert moi je vous remercie évidemment
tous les deux guy forget yannick noah
pour avoir accepté de vous soumettre à
notre questionnement une réflexion et à
participer finalement avec nous à cet
enjeu de mieux comprendre l'évasion
fiscale ça a été dit vous êtes parent
parce que vous avez fait vous avez été
capitaine de l'équipe de france tous les
deux vous avez remporté des coupes davis
au titre de votre nouveau fonctions de
manager de cette équipe tous les deux
vous avez donc porté finalement les
couleurs de la france au plus haut
niveau de notre nation vous avez 20 pour
yannick maintenant c'est aussi toute une
carrière de chanteur dont nous sommes
fiers puisque la popularité était
présente
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'en
fait finalement vous êtes des icônes de
notre de notre nation est par définition
vous représentez pour beaucoup pour des
gens moyens des gens modestes des
personnes qui vivent dans les quartiers
qui vivent en france vous représentez
l'exemplarité et vous représenter notre
notre nation c'est pourquoi je crois que
il ya double un double regard que nous
pouvons porter le regard d'une nation
fière de ses compétiteurs que vous avez
été de cette exemplarité du savoir faire
et du savoir être et de de votre
réussite
et puis en même temps le besoin de vous
retrouver à travers la fiscalité comme
étant présent sur notre sol en 91 92 93
yannick noah avait fait le choix de
vivre en suisse
guy forget vous l'avez dit très gentil
très correctement à l'instant même
également et ça pour chacun de gérer
pour les gens pour les habitants de
notre pays
pour les français c'est quelque chose
qui est pas forcément compris parce que
même si c'est pas une fraude
c'est considérer quand même finalement
bien une évasion d'une manière ou d'une
autre et on est bien de sur ce sujet et
donc ça ne peut pas être bien ressenti
parce que vous êtes ces icônes que nous
voulons porter comme étant dans
l'exemplarité qui est évoqué par mon
collègue m
ce temps donc ça m'interroge parce que
je me dis si vous avez eu et vous avez
vous l'avez justifier cette attitude
comment peut-on penser qu'avec 1 75% là
d'un million d'euros qui est le cas qui
vous touche et qui touche d'autres
d'autres peu d'autres personnalités
on peut penser que les comportements
changeront je crois pas que ce soit
incitatif à faire revenir en arrière au
contraire je pense qu'ils auront une
accélération de ce mouvement là et que
ce que l'on veut gagner d'un côté on le
perdra de l'autre parce que évidemment
on pourra toujours dire que c'est bien
de reconnaître le drapeau français c'est
bien de rester dans son pays et payer
des rues de la fiscalité c'est bien la
solidarité
mais dans la réalité on retombera dans
très exactement ce que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure le phénomène une carrière
courte et quand on a une carrière courte
évidemment on optimise et vous l'avez
justifié je dirais avec courage auprès
de nous et je tiens à vous en remercier
parce que c'est cette réalité kellal
qu'est la nôtre il faut la prendre en
considération moi j'ai envie que nous
vedette j'ai envie que ce qui porte les
couleurs de la france aussi bien vous
avez pu la porter ceux qui nous font
honneur ceux qui font que les
populations vivre ce qui nous donne du
plaisir nous avait du plaisir en 83
quand yannick noah 1 gagne roland garros
et ça s'est pas reproduit depuis nous
avions été très fier et j'étais de
ceux-là qui était devant son poste de
télé enthousiasme avoir cette réussite
et cette belle victoire
nous avons envie que ça se reproduise et
nous avons envie que nos coûts nos
sportifs restent sur le territoire
français donc je pense que cette mesure
de 75% et pas une bonne mesure dans la
mesure où elle s'arrête à une situation
qui ne conduira pas finalement à de bons
résultats ce que je tends de notre thé
nation par ailleurs je voudrais
simplement dire j'ai compris
complètement cette question des
cheminements jeu par là que la
problématique des carrières courtes on
parle des sportifs on peut parler des
chanteurs des chanteurs peuvent avoir un
succès fou pendant une période très
court on l'a vu on a des exemples de
personnes qui à un moment donné on est
des vedettes des stars dont la durée de
carrière était très court c'est pas le
cas de yannick noah mais c'est le cas de
d'autres personnes
le succès littéraire peut aussi conduire
à un moment donné par un best-seller à
avoir des revenus sur une période
extrêmement courtes tout à fait
sympathique mais qui vont pas durer dans
le temps une vie professionnelle
métier vous pouvez avoir un moment donné
dans votre carrière une promotion qui
vous tous qui vous amène à des revenus
importants mais qui ne dureront pas dans
une carrière antérieure j'ai eu
comment a été un joueur à un footballeur
français d'origine sénégalaise qui
commet a été décrété un quelqu'un de
très connu en france qui était un cas
est éclatée en division ac a joué à
nantes
je vais pas aller plus loin sinon sera
qu il est et que j'ai quittée dans une
gestion catastrophique catastrophique et
qui a été que nous avons embauché comme
chauffeur c'est pour vous dire la
situation entre une période où on peut
gagner énormément d'argent et finalement
une situation qui devient miséreuse
parce qu'en fait on vient dans une
gestion difficile
un âge très jeune alors qu'on a appris à
dépenser beaucoup lorsqu'on a gagné
beaucoup d'argent et qui n'ont pas été
forcément bien nous accompagner ce qui
me fait dire sur ce point là c'est que
je pense que le vrai problème à gérer
c'est la question de l'échelonnement
finalement de ce cette période qui fait
que finalement notre fiscalité elle
porte sur des revenus sur une année
alors qu'en réalité on devrait à mesurer
les choses plutôt sur une échelle
beaucoup plus longue
lié à bien des situations qui font que
contrairement à beaucoup les revenus
deviennent en fin de carrière vous les
avez plutôt en début de carrière avec
évidemment des situations plus
difficiles après donc je crois qu entre
une réflexion du fiscaliste à apporter
deux législateurs que nous sommes sur
comment essayer de de contribuer à un
livre est peut-être un phénomène qui
n'est pas à l'échelle d'une année mais à
l'échelle d'une vie où et qui bien
évidemment qu'on se fait qu'il ya des
phénomènes de succès d'autres de moindre
de moindres aux moindres revenus
voilà donc moi je tiens à nos sportifs
je tiens à ce que vous êtes je suis très
très heureux de vous voir ici autour de
cette table et je vous demande qu'est ce
que vous pensez d'abord effectivement
sur les 75 % est ce que ce raisonnement
qui consiste à penser que naturellement
et vous l'avez montré par vous même il y
aura une tentation à prendre des
résidences à l'étranger
ce s'accentuera malgré les bonnes
volontés de certains dont vous faites
partie
et deuxièmement comment faire en sorte
de
réfléchir à un autre mode de
fiscalisation qui prendrait en
considération
un cas de figure qui est celui que vous
présenter avec d'une durée très courte
dans dans le succès quoique vous vous
avez fait une longue carrière je pense à
l'année comme pratiquement moi je ne
peux je parle en mon nom je ne peux pas
parler au nom de tous les sportifs et
tous les artistes
j'ai arrêté ma carrière sportive ya 20
ans à l'époque où les les gains étaient
nettement inférieurs à ce qu'ils étaient
aujourd'hui et dans les dix premiers
mondiaux aujourd'hui on fait une
carrière aujourd'hui et puis à moins de
tomber sur un un escroc môme on peut
vivre et faire vivre sa famille pendant
une ou voire deux générations donc c'est
quand même très différent de ce qui me
concerne est ce qui nous a plu aux
concernées nous devait s'occuper de la
de l'après tennis quasiment le lendemain
des décisions de retraite quoi donc moi
en fait j'ai décidé ma décision d'aller
m'installer en suisse en 91 c'était le
lendemain ma retraite j'ai arrêté en 90
ans 91 et un en suisse justement
simplement parce que j'avais la crainte
du lendemain voilà c'est très simple
c'était avantageux pour moi après il ya
eu un mode de vie est elle un certain
nombre de choses à faire pour pour
continuer ce cette vie à montreux et
puis au bout du bout de trois ans
c'était un petit peu long et j'ai décidé
de revenir en france
d'autant plus que grâce à un petit peu à
guy j'ai eu des revenus inespéré à
savoir que m'a permis de gagner la coupe
davis en tant que capitaine donc j'ai
gagné un petit peu de sou merci non je
te dis va à 22 22 ans après celui
et donc voilà c'était j'avais arrêté de
jouer je devenu capitaine pendant trois
ans et c'est vrai que j'ai des revenus à
ce moment là le joueur de tennis gagne
la plupart de ses revenus à l'étranger
enfin c'est vraiment différent
il ya une grosse différence entre gagner
des sous et là je je je je peux faire la
différence justement avec le chanteur
que je suis maintenant je fais entre
guillemets toute ma carrière à 80 % de
ma carrière en france
il est hors de question que j'aille
ailleurs je gagne mon argent ici je paye
mes impôts ici naturellement je vis ici
je serai une vedette internationale sur
le plan artistique peut-être que la
question se poserait est ce que si
demain je vais jouer faire cinquante
concerts aux états unis et que je gagne
50 fois ce que viennent ici parce que
tout est multiplié par 50 est ce que
j'aurai envie de revenir payer mes
impôts ici certainement pas certainement
pas même si j'adore chanter la
marseillaise même si je suis prêt à me
battre pour les couleurs de mon pays
c'est une question de personnel peut
être égoïste à ce moment là mais mais là
le problème se pose pas je gagne mon âge
ainsi je gagne mon argent ici grâce au
public français
quand il semble normal de partager avec
le public français
je veux pas conseillé à mon fils de qui
a fait toute sa carrière aux états unis
de venir payer 75% ici ce serait
aberrant
par contre moi je pense que c'est normal
que je paie 75% pour répondre à votre
question de 75%
je suis pas la tête d'une grande
compagnie avec plusieurs antennes à
l'étranger c'est pas mon cas voilà vous
avez là très précis par un na'vi très
tranchées pour ses 75 % donc le mien
aussi assez tranché oui je trop parler
monsieur bécaud voilà oui merci à vous
deux il faut j'ai gagné trois mois je
voudrais revenir sur la double
imposition parce que j'ai pas très bien
compris il faudrait que vous nous
apporter quelques précisions sur cette
double imposition d'une part de ensuite
comment le joueur de tennis se déplace
et est ce que ces voyages sont prises en
charge totale et c'est ça aussi c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne connaît mal et et
3 effectivement je pense qu'il me paraît
important que l'on puisse ensemble
réfléchir nous parlementaires mais vous
sportifs ou artistes réfléchir à la mise
en place d'une fiscalité qui soit plus
approprié compte tenu des carrières très
courte
je crois que ce serait en effet comme le
disait tout à l'heure aux collègues je
prends il faudrait voir globalement les
choses parce que pour les grands joueurs
pour les les 10 ou 15 du top mondial ça
ne pose pas de problème je comprends que
yannick qui fait lui une carrière une
double carrière sur le plan national
comme artiste je confonds 6e lui pose
pas de problème mais pour certains qui
gagnent beaucoup moins d'argent ils
peuvent à un moment donc payer beaucoup
et puis après se retrouver un petit peu
un peu misérable je dirais pour essayer
d'action que les choses donc c'est un
petit peu à 7 pour cette raison que je
dirais il ya peut-être là vraiment une
réflexion à mener ensemble les élus et
les sportifs et les sports de nouveau de
haut niveau et les artistes
merci pour pau pour répondre à votre
faim votre question concernant donc les
puisque vous c'est sur la question vous
posiez par rapport aux frais d'un jean
tennis contrairement au football
beaucoup d'autres sports
le jour été dit s'il est son propre
patron et c'est lui qui rémunère son
entraîneur son préparateur physique et
lula semble de charge
aujourd'hui on va dire qu'un joueur qui
est dans les 100 meilleurs jeunes a pas
de federer nadal qui voyagent dans des
conditions différentes à 15 avec un
staff très important mais on a calculé
que ça lui revient environ à 125 1000
euros de frais par an sur ses voyages
c'est lui qui paye son billet d'avion
c'est lui qui paiera ses repas c'est lui
qui paye le salaire de son entraîneur le
salaire de son préparateur physique et
forcément la chance parce que sa chambre
d'hôtel celle du joueur elle est prise
en charge quand il va jouer à bercy ou
ailleurs ou à l'étranger et par contre
pour son entraîneur et son préparateur
physique
c'est lui qui doit payer la chambre donc
on arrive à des grosso modo chaque
l'australien ça lui coûte 135 140 mille
euros le joueur européen je crois que
c'est 120 125 milles et puis certains
c'est un petit peu moins m'enfin c'est
aux alentours de 125 1000 euros de frais
c'est ce que c'est ce que un joueur doit
débourser au minimum par an
pour poursuivre le circuit de manière de
manière générale une nouvelle fois pour
revenir aux joueurs français là des
joueurs français qui sont résidents à
l'étranger aujourd'hui ils se doivent
être 7,8
il ya sept huit joueurs français qui ont
choisi de d'élire domicile à l'étranger
ce que diliani tout à l'heure sur tous
leurs revenus français par contre c'est
à dire qu'ils jouent beaucoup en france
y'a un la coupe davis il ya roland
garros et à bercy avant de montpellier
là marseille et à metz et rejoint les
joueurs français jouent la plupart de
ces temps - là une fois qu'ils auront
fait gérés qu'ils ont fait leur déclarer
au fisc à la fin de l'année ils vont
payer quasiment je parle de ces six sept
joueurs là ils vont déplacer la tranche
maximale en france je peux qu'elle de
calendale exactement enfin mis la
caunette que moi mais ils vont être
taxés donc quasiment à 50%
donc voilà pour les doubles impositions
mais rafael nadal et roger federer
sont dans le même processus aujourd'hui
eux sont étrangers mais ils doivent
faire une déclaration complémentaire à
la fin d'année parce qu'ils n'ont pas
seulement jouer roland-garros il en joue
aussi bercy ils ont joué dos tourné en
france il s'en offusque pas d'ailleurs
ils jouent ces tournois là comme le dit
yannick federer et nadal jouer
roland-garros de même même s'il n'y
avait pas de prize money c'est quelque
chose en terme d'image qui est tellement
fort pour eux néanmoins je dirais ils
sont taxés
aujourd'hui sur ces montants là et si je
peux prendre entre guillemets la la
défense un peu d'aidé de ses joueurs
français qui sont aujourd'hui dans
l'étranger comme l'a dit yannick surtout
ce qu'il gagne en france ils payent la
moitié
alors après la question de savoir est ce
que suffisant ou pas c'est un autre
débat est-ce qu'il faut l'échelonner sûr
on peut à plus forte raison si on passe
demain à 75%
effectivement ce sera toujours beaucoup
d'argent est ce qu'il faut l'échelonner
je crois que c'est aujourd'hui à vous de
2,2 réfléchir justement à une fiscalité
qui peut être peut-être à plusieurs
paliers enfin étalé dans le temps
je pense pas que les joueurs aujourd'hui
puissent vous suggérer des idées je sais
que certains d'entre eux trouvent à lait
normal de payer 50% de leurs revenus
mais à un moment donné ils disent bon
match comme quand je suis aux états unis
qu'en chine en australie quand je suis
dans tous les autres pays du monde
pas si je peux ne pas re encore payer 50
suspects rendent ce massacre économiser
20 donc c'est une optimisation fiscale
et en aucun cas je dire pour les joueurs
de tennis je suis bien sûr ces six ou
sept garçons dont on parle que de six ou
sept garçons là ce n'est pas je pense
dans l'esprit de deux femmes dans leur
esprit une évasion fiscale alors c'est
perçu d'ailleurs de là par ses membres
des médias et même parfois du grand
public comme des joueurs qui sont un des
garçons qui fuit qu'ils payent pas leurs
impôts et alors qu'on va et allemands
c'est pas le cas monsieur du verre noir
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier guy forget on
partage ou pas son opinion il a le son
propos a le mérite d'être articulé est
clair cela étant dit dans votre vie
professionnelle monsieur noir comme
sportif est comme artiste de variétés
aussi bien entendu dans votre engagement
citoyen vous avez toujours défendu au
sens large du terme
la justice sociale c'est une attitude
qui vous honore mais la justice sociale
dans une république comme la nôtre
repose d'abord sur la justice fiscale
celle qui permet de collecter l'impôt
ici des issues de la création de
richesse individuelle et collective de
manière à pouvoir leur est distribué au
mieux dans un souci d'équité et donc de
justice sociale que vous prenez
cette commission denquête n'est pas sur
l'évasion des capitaux n'est pas un
tribunal administratif
mais elle cherche à comprendre l'état
d'une situation préoccupante à plus d'un
titre pour rétablir les finances de
notre état dont vous connaissez
l'ampleur du déficit
pour ce qui nous concerne aujourd'hui et
mon propos s'adresse particulièrement à
vous nous voudrions comprendre sans
avoir à l'esprit d'un quelconque
jugement moral vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure mais je crois utile de le de
revenir sur cette question ce qui vous a
conduit à faire des économies
ce n'est pas une expression personnelle
c'est la vôtre dans en suisse dans les
années 90 et c'est l'expression vous
avez utilisé publiquement à plusieurs
reprises
vous n'avez encore dit tout à l'heure
relayé par les médias toujours sensible
et prompt à répercuter vos propos ce
choix personnel de vous exiler
fiscalement et le contentieux qui est
encore semble-t-il le vôtre avec le
ministère du budget et il en conformité
avec l'esprit de justice sociale que
vous prenez les citoyens font s'est
imposée est appelée à l'être encore
davantage dans la situation économique
financière et fiscale qui hélas ne
veulent simplement savoir parce qu'au
travers des médias vous apparaissez
comme un exemple de réussite citoyenne
et nous nous en réjouissons
ce que recouvre véritablement votre
attitude vos engagements pour sortir et
je m'exprime en tant que citoyen elle me
fait la voix de ce que j'entends autour
de moi ici elle a d'une certaine
ambiguïté entre la vertu civique que
tout le monde partage
et une problématique d'évasion fiscale
qui semblerait être encore la vôtre je
remercie
il m'avait semblé clair que cet aspect
n'allait pas te n'avait pas discuté de
cette partie disons que je suis
effectivement procédure effectivement
procédure le fisc réclame une somme pour
l'année fiscale 93 que je conteste pour
des raisons que je ne vais bien entendu
pas discuter ici certains pensent qu'il
y à ambiguïté
moi je pense que je défends mes droits
comme tout citoyen le fisc m'a réclamé
de l'argent et je le conteste c'était il
ya dix neuf ans je le conteste je
continuerai à le contester jusqu'au
moment où la justice décidera au jeu à
l'heure où on parle je ne dois rien tout
je ne dois rien enfin je sais pas je ne
dois rien pour ce qui est don de
l'exemplarité je pense qu'il ya des
premièrement effectivement très
important de s'acquitter de l'impôt et
pour certains plus rare d'aller au delà
et ça ça je ne suis pas venu ici pour
expliquer combien quand
je reverse à la société voilà encore une
fois je suis très déçu parce qu'on
m'avait vraiment dit que je n'allais pas
on n'allait pas aborder ce sujet ici
mais je ne suis pas non plus surpris je
suis pas non plus surpris et j'espère
que ma réponse vous convient je crois
qu'il faut préciser les choses je vois
pas quel sujet on n'aurait pas abordé
dans une commission denquête je sais pas
ce qu'il faisait était dit mais d'abord
je crois qu'il ya près de la procédure
la procédure une procédure oui mais
justement j'ai cru comprendre comme je
suis jeune et c'est dur et je voudrais
que vous êtes un citoyen comme moi comme
nous tous et dans cette maison où nous
avons liberté de parole est devenu
d'expression en notant que les choses
sont exprimé d'une manière posée
réfléchie et respectueuse de l'autre ce
que j'ai fait avec vous oui c'est bien
ce que j'ai compris il est évident que
nous ne voulons pas rentrer dans des cas
particuliers
c'est ce qu'a dit d'ailleurs je crois
l'ensemble des collègues et que c'est
pour cela qu'on ne rentre pas pour
autant on est quand même obligé de de
savoir gérer excusez-moi j'ai bien que
j'ai cru comprendre qu'on s'avance cela
c'était un cas particulier non enfin je
sais pas j'ai mal compris je crois
qu'ils appellent j'aimerais qu'on aille
les particuliers qui ont été évoqués
nommé jeu alors essayer de compléter
peut-être l'interrogation de mes
collègues en tout cas moi j'ai une
interrogation formulée
nous avons interrogé les gens du
football actuellement il ya l'or au foot
il ya cinq grands pays l'allemagne
l'italie l'espagne l'angleterre qui
participent et l'équipe de france si on
espère comme tout le monde
grand succès à l'équipe de france c'est
un sport collectif bon de ces cinq
équipes en europe on parle pas on
pourrait parler de la hollande et
d'autres la seule équipe nationale dont
la majorité parfois c'est les deux tiers
selon les sélections des joueurs qui la
composent sont des joueurs qui doivent
faire leurs patients à l'étranger leur
métier à l'étranger et je pense pas qu
effectivement quelqu'un qui veuille
faire le sport le plus populaire du
monde entre 18 et 25 ans sa
préoccupation c'est l'exil fiscal mais
c'est un constat
c'est la même chose pour nos artistes
pour nous tous les acteurs du cinéma
ils sont les chauffeurs de formule 1
c'est comme ça qu'on a amené à vous
convoquez ou à vous demander de
témoigner et de participer et et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une certaine
incompréhension pas ce que vous dites
j'avais peur ce que je comprends très
bien puis à 20 ans les situations
étaient pas les mêmes etc et donc je
suis parti parce que j'avais peur je
voulais faire des économies et c'est la
logique même et en même temps j'ai une
carrière courte mais je crois que dans
tous les métiers généralement sauf dans
le vôtre quoi sauf lors dallas où il ya
un talent particulier
souvent on n'est pas dix ans dans les
hauts revenus parfois ça arrive en fin
de carrière la plupart du temps dans le
monde des affaires ce que je lis dire
comme peut-être un de mes collègues ça
arrive les dernières années on est
rarement pdg à 25 ans jusqu'à 65 ans et
plus souvent dans les hauts revenus de
55 ans à 65 ans c'est à dire c'est une
carrière courte à l'envers ce qui se
passe pour beaucoup de contribuables
vous vous avez le fait de dire
effectivement mon une carrière courte
très jeunes face à des responsabilités
et puis on ne sait pas comment faire
mais c'est quand même malheureux pour un
pays d'avoir la nécessité de dire je
suis obligé de partir trois ans à
l'étranger parce que j'ai besoin de
faire des économies
parce que j'ai une certaine angoisse
pour la vie et puis après
ça a été évoqué à plusieurs reprises aux
optimisations économie vous avez toute
cette angoisse et après je peux revenir
parce que la vie effectivement après une
fois que j'ai fait l'optimisation on
peut revenir et puis je dirais ça c'est
une situation un peu curieuse parce que
vis à vis des générations qui vous de
succèdent
vous pourriez dire il faudrait peut-être
changer pourquoi on n'est pas comme les
amants pas comme les anglais pas comme
les espagnols pas comme les italiens
c'est un peu bizarre comme attitude moi
j'ai été choqué par les propos que vous
avez tenus tout à l'heure vous choquer
étonné je veux dire en termes de
compréhension je dirais je comprend
peut-être beaucoup de choses vous dites
je le dirai pas mon fils à moi oui bah
moi je suis en france toute façon ma
carrière moi je suis partie au moment où
il fallait partir et puis bah maintenant
j'ai un public français alors je veux
bien payer mes impôts en france 75% mais
mon fils qu aux etats unis 75 % c'est
aberrant alors j'étais mais c'est pas
l'exemplarité ça il jouait mon fils mon
fils joue dans des salles et vous savez
moi je suis plutôt partisan que les
talents s'expriment franchement et je
trouve tout à fait anormal que des cons
riche et dans le cinéma
dès qu'on réussit dans la science et
qu'on réussit quelque part on soit
obligé de partir et vous qu'être parti
qui est revenu expliquez-nous pourquoi
pourquoi mais alors là c'est vrai que je
comprends l'interrogation d'un collègue
l'hiver n'aura pas ce que je dis pour
mon fils je le fais pas je n'aurai que
excusez moi peut-être jolie précise je
voulais c'est comme mon fils je le ferai
pas je ne ferai pas mon fils un ami mon
fils est engagée par une compagnie
privée qui s'appelle la nba c'est un
sport professionnel mais c'est la nba
voilà ce sont des équipes privées il se
trouve que il joue dans des conditions
non mais les bons les sportifs et plein
d'enfants sont passionnés par ce sport
en fait ces voix là ils se sont dédits
joue tous les soirs dans les salles de
30000 personnes on n'a pas de ça le
trente mille personnes donc il ya des
droits tv qui sont pas les mêmes droits
télé donc il a des revenus qui sont pas
les mêmes que les revenus qu'il aurait
ici au même niveau donc voilà ça c'est
clair vous parlez de l'équipe de france
2 2
de foot ou certes la plupart ne sont pas
mais l'équipe de france de basket ils
sont juste tous aux états unis et
viennent jouer pour l'équipe de france
avec plaisir vienne s'acquitter à tous
leurs devoirs entre guillemets mais leur
profession les amène à jose états unis
voilà c'est ça ce niveau là que je dirai
ce que je trouverais intéressant de se
poser une réflexion collective entre
élus personnes qui sont confrontées à
cette situation de dire il ya quand même
un problème puisque ça se produit quand
france plutôt que de dire qu'ils vont
faire leur carrière aux états unis ils
sont déjà de réaliser leur carrière
professionnelle et puis dix ans après
ils vont venir et puis toute façon là il
y aura plus de piques de salaires donc
on pourra revenir en france et générer
se mettre dans le moule de la société
française avec ses interrogations avec
ses contraintes mais on est quand même
un pays où finalement tout le monde est
obligé de partir et vous revenez après
dix ans après pour dire ah ben oui
finalement c'est bien 75% ou pas 64 90
le détail je veux dire c'est que
lorsqu'on à monsieur thierry bourcy
c'est une bonne chose pour le football
français pour les clubs la compétitivité
puisque vous avez cité le mot de
compétitivité tout à l'heure c'était
intéressant en dix ans évidemment attia
tournoi comparables on a craint de
compétitivité pass est peut-être plus
simple de dire des choses maintenant que
les vire avec un recul lorsque
finalement on a perdu la compétition
lorsque je joue au tennis moi j'étais en
france
déjà lorsque j'ai joué il ya déjà des
certains sportifs français qui font
toute leur carrière et leur après
carrière à l'étranger
je vous ai parlé de mes trois ans et pas
que j'ai passé trois ans en suisse d'un
couche survenue parce que y avait une
opportunité
enfin le livre il ya une différence
le
j'ai pris le cas de mon fils parce que
c'est un sport vraiment très très
particulier et précis c'est là c'est
vraiment parle d' extrême
c'est effectivement le cas du basket est
vraiment par rapport à d'autres sports
où effectivement notre sport où on peut
continuer à mener une carrière en france
pour ce qui est du basket appartement on
touche le haut niveau c'est quasiment
impossible et c'est pas ça ne touche pas
que la france et d'autres pays européens
la plupart des joueurs européens
maintenant la possibilité de et partant
à l'étranger
pour ce qui est des joueurs de tennis
aujourd'hui à l'époque certains étaient
à l'étranger mais aujourd'hui ils sont
tous à l'étranger et ils vivent
donc voilà c'est c'était pour justement
pour éclairer je vends mon point de vue
personnel et expliquer un peu mon bon
parcours
et oui au bout de trois ans j'ai décidé
de venir parce qu'il y avait un mode de
vie qui ne me satisfaisait pas même si
j'avais envie de faire des économies
jeudi j'étais en été on se voyait voilà
cesser
seuls propos était d'y être c'est
peut-être pour vous l'occasion de la
parole puisque il y en a qui sont dans
cette situation et addictif et qui eux
sont contraints d'être à l'étranger pour
l'instant et que vous dites tout à fait
naturellement finalement ben si j'avais
d'ailleurs vous l'avais dit je crois
d'une autre manière c'est ici je si
j'avais été mes concerts aux états unis
devant un public américain
peut-être que moi aussi je me poserai la
question qu'on se pose un peu pour sa
conscience et la session d'hier pour les
générations actuelles ceux qui sont
interactifs et qui sont dans cette
situation ça voudrait bien la peine
contenu de votre expérience de dire bah
oui il ya eu des contraintes et il ya
l'optimisation c'est la réponse à
peut-être une certaine contrainte ou aux
pressions qui à un moment donné est trop
forte hausse et visa parce que on a le
sentiment que vous êtes à gérer d'un pas
dans la même situation lorsqu'on est au
coeur de la carrière ou après la
carrière et je dirais face à cette
contrainte
enfin pour pas pour monopoliser le
dialogue j'ai passé la période
la parole à monsieur vaugrenard et puis
après on pourra porter comme quoi le
soit rapidement monsieur le président je
suis surpris de l'intervention de mon
collègue et de celle qui a suivi de la
vôtre monsieur le président ce que je me
pose la question je vous le dis
franchement si la question a été posée à
yannick noah seulement de manière
suggestive
parce que ses orientations politiques
des pleurs est peut-être un peu
déplairait peut-être un peu nous avons
eu beaucoup d'auditions depuis quelques
mois c'est la première fois que je
constate ce comportement met en cause
personnellement
l'une des personnes que l'on additionne
donc permettez moi d'être interrogatif
sur les raisons de ces questions
particulières qui sont posées moi ce que
je constate c'est que la réponse de
yannick noah
par rapport à ce moment où il est allé
ensuite allé en suisse
c'était par rapport à la crainte de
l'avenir par rapport à un certain nombre
d'auditions certain nombre
d'organisations également fortement
conseillé par des avocats fiscalistes en
particulier par rapport à également à
l'évasion fiscale concernant les
héritages et le patrimoine immobilier
tous ces évasions fiscales à voir toutes
ces fraudes fiscales selon moi sont
guidés par une forme de cupidité
exacerbé ce qui n'est pas le cas selon
la réponse de yannick noah est la
démonstration qui est fait chaque jour
de son engagement humaniste par rapport
à d'autres auditions que nous avons
effectués donc je ne comprends pas bien
cette manière de d'intervenir
la question qui devra se poser à nous
très clairement et très sereinement et
il aurait été intéressant du reste dans
toutes nos éditions d'avoir un témoin
citoyens qui lui était bien en dessous
d'un million d'euros mais qui avait
simplement un salaire médian de 1600
euros
c'est à dire la moyenne des salariés
français pour avoir son opinion aussi
sur l'exemplarité qui est indispensable
et qui est nécessaire ça ne signifie pas
je leur dis à nouveau qu'il ne faut pas
être attentionné au fait que les
sportifs ont des carrières courtes mais
à ce moment là c'est pas par une
démarche individuelle que la solution
peut être apportée c'est par une
réflexion une démarche collective et ça
ça nous regarde
c'est de notre responsabilité est donc
lorsqu'on parle de cela je pense qu'il
faut le faire sereinement et au moment
où nous aurons avec le rapporteur qui a
fait un travail remarquable faire des
propositions j'attends de voir
c'est qu'aujourd'hui semble d'une grande
virulence de savoir si les propositions
qui seront faites ça serait une
diminution d'impôts généralisées ou une
augmentation d'impôts en direction de
ceux qui peuvent participer à l'effort
collectif et là nous verrons vraiment
quel est le fond du fond de la pensée de
chacun et au delà discours de savoir ce
que nous proposons parce que la
situation est difficile et parfois
catastrophique est donc majeur exact je
le dis un conte utilise une audition
pour mettre en cause quelqu'un qui non
seulement a porté haut les couleurs de
notre pays mais aussi à montrer par une
démarche humanitaire quotidienne qu'il
était au service du collectif
avant de passer la parole à monsieur
bériault et vos rapporteurs comme vous
m'avez mis en cause je vais quand même
faire une précision je veux dire j'ai
noté le témoin citoyens mais ça c'est au
rapporteur qui conviendra de de
sélectionner un témoin citoyens
représentatifs de la population
française pourquoi on puisse
l'auditionner donc je vous laisse le
soin de le trouver
je pense qu'un chiot noir que
je n'ai pas voulu je ne pensais pas
faire de la politique en nous
interpellant sur les réactions parce que
encore une fois et je vous le dis à tous
les deux on vous remercie vraiment
devenir mais il faut quand même qu'on
puisse établir un dialogue et le
dialogue avec des sportifs ce qu'on n'a
pas voulu faire avec le football
pourquoi on allait prendre tel ou tel
joueur de football
c'était difficile pourquoi on prendrait
tel acteur éventuellement ou chanteurs
vous vous avez l'avantagé d'être à la
fois sportif et le chanteur donc au
moins on avait le monde culturel et le
monde sportif et cette question je leur
ai posé de toute manière parce que le
cher collègue vous savez très bien que
ce type de questions je les pose souvent
tellement je suis exaspéré de voir un
certain nombre de nos élites quitter
notre pays et les peaux crise et qui
consiste à glorifier un certain nombre
de personnes et c'est pour ça que j'ai
pris l'exemple du football par exemple
puisque c'est d'actualité de dire ben
oui c'est très bien et puis en même
temps on accepte que dans football dans
le tennis on nous a parlé de la formule
1 nous a parlé de prix nobel qui avaient
été obligés aussi de partir et que tous
ces gens là doivent en partie s'exiler
pour maintenant si vous voulez qu'on
commence à rentrer dans l'explication
politique et argumentée je suis prêt à
vous suivre
mais je n'ai pas voulu faire je dirais
dans ma réponse ou vis-à-vis de mona cas
particulier j'ai voulu saisir l'occasion
qui l'exprimé très franchement d'abord
le malaise qu'a un jeune joueur qui se
trouve à 23 ans face à une préoccupation
qui est je dirais presque une carrière
libéral les finalement dans une activité
libérale il est seul face à de réels ses
responsabilités parfois les parents
lorsque ce fonds les joueuses de tennis
et donc il a voulu tout simplement je
dirais et c'est s est exprimé ou
optimiser ou économiser ou prévoir la
retraite et j'ai voulu profiter de
l'incompréhension qu'il y avait en
parlant d'une situation qui lui était
personnelle c'est lui qui l'a évoqué
donc j'ai pas compris parce que d'un
côté souhaité s'exprimer
en soutenant une proposition vous
défendre avec acharnement que je
comprends très bien on fera le débat
budgétaire une autre fois et en même
temps dire mais c'est aberrant et je
ferai pas donc c'est tout ce que j'ai
voulu faire et je ne voulais pas
remettre en cause la notoriété d'un
sportif comme monsieur forget qui veut
vous croire sur ce plan là nous sommes
unanimes
je passe la parole à la géniale oui
merci monsieur le président en tant que
président de cette commission je n'ai
pas la même lecture qui vient d'être
donné je pense que c'est très important
que nous ayons une libre expression et
que les choses puissent porter notamment
sur des témoignages et si nous avons eu
deux témoignages et évidemment je
souhaite je tiens à les remercier une
fois encore de cette franchise parce
qu'elle nous apporte
elle nous apporte en termes de comment
contribuer à faire en sorte que nos
intérêts se rencontrent les intérêts des
joueurs c'est à dire qu'ils sont
foncièrement attaché à un territoire
dans lequel ils ont débloqué lille ont
défendu les couleurs et les intérêts de
nos concitoyens qui est de conserver ces
décès c'est cette image comme étant
l'image de la france et je crois que
c'est ça qui friment fondamentalement
est important et à ce titre je trouve
qu'il est important il est aussi
nécessaire de toucher les points qui
peuvent à un moment donné nous permettre
d'avancer moi j'en ai retenu 3 j'ai
retenu le point sur la question qu'on a
discuté sur les 75 % qui restent à bas
qui reste une interrogation pour moi la
question des échelonnements pour essayer
de visualiser comment prendre en
considération c'est que ces carrières
courtes et puis dire et un troisième
point qui est évoqué par parier que
yannick noah qui sera peut-être un
élément sur lequel il faudra aussi
discuter je pense à la question de
l'engagement sociétal des joueurs parce
que effectivement il peut y avoir une
contribution solidaire à travers une
prise d'engagements qui appâtent de fait
des mouvements sur com com s'est fait
dans le cas de la de l'association sur
sur sportive dans le domaine du tennis
qui a été initiée par une histoire je
pense que ce sont des bonnes choses donc
il faut aussi en parler il faut
peut-être aussi le prendre en
considération dans la réflexion et
pourquoi pas même dans la réflexion
fiscale et solidaire qui est la nôtre
voilà donc merci à vous tous et je
trouve que c'est une excellente un
excellent moment des changes président
elle rapporte m se présente jours et je
permettais sortir un peu de ces
considérations personnelles pour revenir
à un cadre plus large je précise que le
rapport qui sera rendu dans quelques
semaines et dont j'espère qu'il le sera
soutenu par la majorité cette commission
si c'est nous les limites et consistera
d'abord en état des lieux général de la
situation qui nous préoccupe
une analyse qui je pense mettre en
évidence que c'est bien tout un système
qui s'est mise en place à l'échelle
planétaire
nous avons eu l'occasion de visionner
des grands responsables d'entreprises
industrielles bancaire
on constate aussi que le domaine de
l'art est touché par ce cancer j'ai dit
ça comme un cancer financier le domaine
du sport et toucher le club d'arsenal a
mis en place une société à jersey par
exemple et on pourrait ainsi multiplier
les exemples et suscité l'indignation
parce qu'il y à beaucoup d'indignation
et au delà des murs de cette enceinte je
crois il faut pas l'oublier
donc c'est un phénomène très large que
nous décrivons que nous tentons
d'analyser et surtout que nous nous
proposerons nous ferons des propositions
concrètes y compris législatives dans le
rapport qui sera soumis à l'échangé à la
réflexion et au vote de chacun voilà
j'aurai à bord des deux questions
concrètes qui nous ramène à notre sujet
et ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure est ce
que vous l'un et l'autre vous seriez
scandalisé ou quel est votre avis sur
l'idée de lier l'impôt à la nationalité
indépendamment du lieu de résidence les
américains l'ont fait voilà une
proposition et un avis sur lequel je
voudrais avoir votre sentiment
et ensuite nous allons nous rendre en
suisse en fin de semaine comme je lé
indiqué tout à l'heure et je dois dire
qu'on sent un peu de nervosité
côté suisse un peu de réticence parfois
y compris à nous recevoir et donc quel
est l'état de vos relations avec
l'administration fiscale en suisse vous
avez évoqué de se forger un forfait que
le canton vaud où vous résidez donc quel
est à vos relations avec
l'administration fiscale suisse
et avez-vous ressenti dans la dernière
période un changement d'atmosphère un
espèce de regain de tensions puisque je
disais l'indignation monte dans le monde
depuis quelques années avec cette crise
financière et économique qui fait rage
et donc la suisse se sent un peu mise à
l'index stigmatiser voilà donc nous
allons nous y rendre cette semaine
avez vous de votre point de vue senti
une évolution du climat par rapport à
tous ces sujets ayant trait à la
fiscalité l'imposition des résidents
étrangers
côté non je suis pas je passe senti
aujourd'hui de changement dans les
mentalités maintenant je suis pas je
sais pas au coeur du problème parce que
ne suffit pas signé experts fiscalistes
ni avocat né je manquais pas de ces
structures là je ne suis pas je ne
serais pas dans la tranche des plus de
75%
malheureusement j'aimerais bien en faire
partie mais je suis loin de ces revenus
là et pour ce qui est de mon cas
personnel je ne suis pas au forfait ce
qui est le cas parfois de certains gens
qui tiennent personnes qui viennent
s'installer en suisse moi je paye mes
impôts en suisse comme un résident
suisse dont les déclarations fiscales
normal basé sur sur les revenus donc je
vois là pour répondre à votre question
clairement jeu mais je suis peut-être un
petit peu loin de la réalité
peut-être les gens sur place notamment
système financières qui pourront
peut-être mieux vaut pour enseigner que
moi dernière question que sur le parlant
de vous deux a un avis sur la
nationalité non j'ai franchement j'ai
suivi chaque états unis fonctionne comme
ça je n'ai pas de c'était très technique
chez pas si d'autres pays le font aussi
sur le rôle de la fédération française
de tennis en tant qu'instance donc qui
vous fait d'air est ce qu'il ya une
philosophie ce qu'il y a une éthique à
l'oeuvre au sein de la fédération par
rapport à ces démarchages éventuelle de
jeunes joueurs qui montent au regard de
la fiscalité de la citoyenneté utilisons
ce mot est ce que la fft a une
philosophie sur le sujet venant pas du
tout la la la la fédération a une
mission qui consiste à faire la
promotion du jeu la détection de jeunes
garçons et jeunes filles et d'ailleurs
on a la chance d'avoir en france un
système qui fonctionne très bien grâce
notamment au tour de roland garros qui
génèrent des revenus considérables et
tout cet argent est réinjecté dans dans
la formation et dans les clubs et par
ailleurs dans la réfection du stade de
roland garros
la fédération et n'étant seul je dirais
responsable gir 2 de ses coûts et de ses
investissements donc la fédération est
totalement autonome aujourd'hui et ne
s'occupe pas du tout j'irai 2 du tennis
professionnel
excepté pour la coupe davis puisque elle
incite effectivement nos meilleurs
joueurs a à jouer la coupe davis et je
vais faire une petite parenthèse là
dessus c'est que parfois dans des
réflexions comme quoi certains joueurs
sont bien contents de jouer la coupe
davis mais moi pour avoir des
sélectionneur de cette équipe je crois
qu'on a la chance en france d'avoir des
garçons qui en permanence les
représentent leur pays alors ça va vous
paraître peut-être un petit peu curieux
mais il ya d'autres pays voisin du nôtre
d'autres pays où aujourd'hui même les
équipes nationales pour des joueurs
professionnels ce n'est plus une
priorité tant qu autant pour le football
c'est peut-être des choses qui sont
aujourd'hui incontournables sachez que
dans notre sport
jouer pour son pays aujourd'hui on a la
chance quand même je trouve encore en
france dans certains pays européens
cadets garçons qui défendent encore le
drapeau
il ya d'autres pays je vous dis il ya
des joueurs pour des considérations
purement professionnel parce qu'il ya
d'autres engagements d'autres
compétitions qui parfois font l'impasse
sur la sélection nationale et je trouve
par rapport à ça il ya la fédération
fait un bon boulot et que les joueurs
français même si certains d'entre eux
résident à l'étranger je dirais par
rapport aux équipes nationales jouent le
jeu et heureusement qu'ils le font parce
que s'il le faisait pas je crois que
l'ensemble dirait du tennis français
seraient pénalisés je voudrais ajouter
que pour répondre aux questions en fait
la fédération n'a pas pour objectif de
conseiller les néo les jeunes en matière
fiscale n'y a pas d'accompagnement les
jeunes partis le monde devienne espoir
c'est à dire vers 15 16 ans ont tout de
suite contacté par des agences des
agents et voilà des managers qui
viennent les conseillers chose ils sont
bien on ne se retrouve enfin tennis en
tout cas c'est très rare qui est 2
d'aider des jeunes ou des joueurs qu'ils
se fassent escroqué quoi bon sont bien
accompagné c'est bien organisé bien que
la fédération n'a essayé pas de devoirs
lorsque l on pourrait penser que ce
serait pas mal que la fédération regarde
un peu qu'on peut parler d'une grande
famille vous savez on se connaît tous
en fait voilà il ya le président le
directeur technique national on connaît
on sait on sait tout on connaît les des
agents connaît des agences ce sont des
gens qui avec lesquels on a travaillé
depuis longtemps donc on se connaît on
sait très bien
lorsqu'un jeune espoir en général il va
tout de suite contacté recruter balle et
je dirais mg et on les connaît donc on
sait qu'ils sont ils vont pas partir
comme ça dans la nature
pas d'autres questions sherco gagne très
bien ma mission est vrai cela vous
remercier de ce moment de vérité
instructif pour tous les membres de la
commission et ça nous a permis de gagner
du temps et donc je vous remercie
d'avoir consacré un peu de temps à nos
questions
vous venez de suivre en direct les
auditions de yannick noah et de guy
forget par la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur l'évasion fiscale si
vous souhaitez revoir cette audition
elle est disponible en vod sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr
nous reviendrons bien entendu plus
largement sur ces auditions dans nos
différentes éditions de 19h et de 22h
très belle journée à tous
en 2005
samsonite fabricant américain de bagages
ferme son unique site français à
hénin-beaumont dans le pas-de-calais
le sinn reprise par un constructeur de
panneaux solaires dépose le bilan 18
mois plus tard les salariés licenciés
sans indemnités dénonce une machination
juridico-financière pas un seul panneau
solaire qui a été fabriqué sur le site
reina bull paas donc c'était des
panneaux solaires ont été importés
d'allemagne pour faire croire au
personnel que on pourrait en fait mais
cette pauvre liquidation totale ou la
longue bataille judiciaire de salariés
contre un géant industriel
un documentaire d'hélène desplanques sur
public sénat dimanche à 9 heures suivi
d'un débat animé par élise lucet
et
oh
je vous propose de commencer par la
stratégie de françois hollande alors à
l'époque où il vivait avec ségolène
royal s'était le plus discret du couple
et récemment et bien il a décidé de
présenter sa nouvelle compagne c'était
dans gala valérie est là